Speaker 1: All right, today we're going to
start by looking at how many of his 100 day
promises Joe Biden has accomplished as president,
either partially or fully. And I think it
makes sense to say at the outset that we will
evaluate whether he did the things he promised
to do. The the question of whether he promised
to do the right things is a separate one.
So, like as an example, if Joe Biden promised
to cancel ten thousand dollars in student
debt and did it, but you think he should have
done 50 thousand, these are two different
questions that he promised the right thing
and that he achieved the thing that he promised.
But let's just jump right into it, starting
with climate. The NPR and the AP have really
good trackers on this. And I encourage you
to check out I'm looking at the Associated
Press tracker and it's very, very good. So
on climate for promises Joe Biden has kept,
he has taken executive action to reduce greenhouse
gas emissions. He did rejoin the Paris climate
accord. He supported an amendment to the Montreal
Protocol to curb H.F. Seas. And he has convened
a world climate summit which recently took
place. He did those four things that he promised.
He has not yet done infrastructure that will
sort of be done in a way that takes into account
the big picture climate picture. He just hasn't
done infrastructure yet. He has not taken
steps to conserve, conserve 30 percent of
U.S. lands and waters by 2030. And he has
not received emission reductions commitments
from the shipping and aviation industry on
the economy. Joe Biden has accomplished four
of his five promises. He has extended a pause
on student loan payments. He did pandemic
relief one point nine trillion. He did review
the US supply chain for vulnerabilities in
key sectors. Those have been identified. He
has taken steps to strengthen by American
measures, and he has not yet increased the
corporate tax rate. So four out of five on
economy and taxes. Now, you might be saying,
well, hold on, he made other promises economically.
Yes, but they were not hundred day promises.
We're looking at 100 day promises on government
functioning. He has done three or four. He
tightened ethics rules. He insulated the Justice
Department from politics. He eased federal
unionization restrictions. He did not restore
rules that were weakened by Donald Trump on
gun control. He's really done nothing yet.
He promised to send Congress a gun control
bill. It's sort of partially been met, but
it's not been completed. He promised to reauthorize
the Violence Against Women Act. It's on its
way, but it has not yet been done commissioning
an attorney general report to restructure
agencies to enforce gun laws he's gotten.
Merrick Garland started on it, but it's not
yet been done. And he also promised an FBI
report on how to tighten gun purchase. Background
check loopholes has not been done. Health
care. He made eight promises for his first
hundred days and he's done five. He did do
a massive mandate on federal property. He
rejoined the World Health Organization. He
set up one hundred mass vaccination centers.
He vaccinated one hundred million Americans,
actually two hundred million. And he did deploy
mobile vaccination clinics. He has not expanded
health care access in a meaningful way yet,
and he has not outlined new pandemic measures
for future pandemics that's been requested.
It's sort of, you could say, in process. And
he has not yet reopened most elementary and
middle schools on housing. He said he would
pause evictions and foreclosures, and he did.
And there were some other strategic things
like coming up with a strategy to make housing
a right that's not yet been done. So he did
do one thing on housing. Immigration is a
tough one. There were a lot of immigration
promises made. In fact, seventeen many have
not been accomplished. The naturalization
process hasn't been streamlined. Increases
to the amount of refugees have not taken place.
But he did send Congress an immigration bill,
which he promised to do. He did revise deportation
criteria, although many people would say,
yeah, they were revised, but it's not nearly
enough. He did take steps to reunite separated
migrant families. He did end the travel ban.
He did stop deportations for certain groups.
And with a lot of these with the immigration
stuff, the devil is really in the details
where the promise is very open ended. So you
and I would look at what's going on with deportations
and we would say there's still a ton of them
going on. The promise was to stop deportations
for certain groups and he did sign a memo
on that. But we I don't feel it's nearly enough.
He stopped border wall construction, reversed
the public charge rule for immigrants. And
then there's a whole bunch of other stuff
that is sort of arguably in progress he's
asked for. It hasn't really happened. He.
Promised to freeze deportations for 100 days.
Remember, he did it, but then it was blocked
by a judge on inequality. Basically nothing
has yet been done. He made 12 promises. The
only one that's been accomplished is creating
a a working group, a union issues working
group to deliver a plan on increasing union
membership that's been done. All the other
stuff hasn't, you know, addressing systemic
racism in U.S. institutions, signing the Equality
Act, appointing a commission to study sexual
assault in the military. These are things
that Joe Biden has said he wants done while
being president. So so they're marked as in
process. They have not yet been done. And
then on national security, Joe Biden promised
to rejoin the Iran nuclear deal. He has he
has started that process. It has not happened.
So how do you grade his promises? I mean,
you know, the thing that's tough about this
is a lot of these promises we all knew were
never going to happen, much like with Trump.
We knew where Trump was, never going to build
a wall across the entire border and get Mexico
to pay for it in his first four years. This
was never going to happen. And he failed.
And so it was a promise he failed to deliver
on. Trump was never going to pay off the national
debt in four years. And of course, he blew
it up. Actually, Joe Biden's promises were
more reasonable, but some were still clearly
not going to happen. So if we just grade him
on a percentage basis, it's like a C, if we
grade him based on his intentions via things
he signed orders on, but obviously take longer
than 100 days. And we account for all of the
realities. It's probably like a B plus. But
but with all of these things, the questions
really are how do we interpret his intention
to do something versus the practicality? When
you understand that there are other players
involved, you're going to have to tell me
how how to evaluate that. And ultimately,
voters are going to decide some great things
done. And compared to many other presidents,
this has been one of the most productive first
100 days compared to all the things he promised.
If you just you don't do a curve of any kind
that accounts for practical difficulties,
it's like he's done kind of, you know, half
the stuff or something like that. So let me
know your thoughts on how we should be evaluating
it. I